Kan du fortfarande känna den här känslan av att mitt jobb är inte ett riktigt jobb, alltså att mina kollegor jobbar hos mig, fast då har de liksom inte ett riktigt jobb, utan de hade kunnat gå till ett riktigt företag istället, men de väljer att jobba här hos...
Exakt så känns det.
Exakt, det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Det får det bli, klart, då går vi vidare.
Då säger vi välkommen till podden Sara Lundqvist som är delägare och grundare på Aktivitus.
Jag vet inte hur du beskriver Aktivitus, en testklinik, flera testkliniker.
Ja, flera testkliniker nu.
På Aktivitus, jag drar den korta pitchen nu.
Nej, den långa pitchen du har.
På Aktivitus ser vi till att våra kunder når sina mål och det är mål som är relaterade till kondition oftast, nästan alltid.
En typ kund till oss är en motionär i 35-55-årsåldern, ska springa ledingerloppet eller åka vasaloppet eller kanske cykla vetten undan.
Då kommer man till Aktivitus för att kartlägga sin fysiologi.
Vi har lite olika typer av tester för att träna på styrkor och svagheter och sen hjälper vi till att skräddas ut individuellt en träningsskema.
Så kan man också få hjälp med coaching mot sitt specifika mål.
Så håller vi handen tills dess att man har utvecklats maximalt.
Dels gör vi det.
Sen har vi ett affärsområde där vi också jobbar mot företag och då hjälper vi företagen att vi förflyttar medarbetare från riskgrupp till friskgrupp, kort sagt.
Vi jobbar proaktivt med hälsa.
Jag förstår.
Men så på privatsidan är ni lite mer riktade mot elite-motionärer där och på företag lite mer mot vad ska man säga, folk som ska komma igång.
Det lät nästan så.
Det är sant.
De flesta våra kunder på privatsidan är redan motiverade.
Där handlar det för oss om att styra dem i rätt riktning och ibland till och med bromsa faktiskt.
Det är en väldigt tacksam målgrupp och väldigt rolig att jobba med på så sätt.
De gör ofta som man säger och de förstår varför de ska göra som man säger.
Så motionärer, elite-motionärer är de flesta.
En liten klick, elite-idrottare också.
Men väldigt få procent.
På företagen är det helt vanliga människor som vi bara ska få igång att röra på sig lite mer.
Så där är det istället de motivationen som vi behöver jobba med och hjälpa till med.
Hur ser fördelningen ut på detta?
Hur stort är varje ben?
Friskvården står ju ungefär för 30% av vår omsättning och privatsegmentet resterande väl då.
Så vi kommer ju från det privata och det är det där vi initierar det.
Sen så finns det ju jättepotential inom friskvården och jobba business to business.
Så det är väl faktiskt någonting som vi framöver kommer fokusera lite mer medvetet på.
Jag förstår.
Okej, och ni har flera anläggningar idag.
Ja, stämmer.
Vi startade i Göteborg 20 år sedan och där har vi vår första anläggning.
Sen startade vi i Stockholm för 10 år sedan.
Vi startade i Malmö för 5 år sedan.
Och sen har vi också fyllt på med Linköping och Falun.
Och i oktober i år så startade vi upp i Åre.
Härligt.
Det är ju inte helt logiskt.
Kände ni att nu är vi i Göteborg och nu ska vi dra igång på andra sidan landet?
För det smidig pendling.
Hur gick första tanken på att starta en...
En testlink nummer två.
Ja, varför inte i partil?
Ja, när vi har kört några år i Göteborg så märkte vi att folk var benägna att ta sig från olika delar av Sverige för att komma till oss och ta hjälp på våra kompetens.
Så vi hade en del kunder i Stockholm och sen så har vi väl inte haft någon medveten strategi eller vision om att öppna fler kliniker.
Inte initialt i alla fall, utan det har varit med tillfälligheter och då i samband med att vi började fundera på att expandera och kanske öppna i Stockholm, så var vår nuvarande kollega, John Hasselmack, hörde av sig och var sugen på att starta upp.
Då kände vi att det var en bra match så vi kör.
På den vägen har varit lite grann.
Efter att vi har startat upp i Stockholm så kändes det mer naturligt att öppna tredje kliniken i Malmö, så det var lite mer strategiskt så klart.
Men sen har det varit väldigt viktigt att i samband med att vi vill starta en ny testklinik, har rätt person, snarare det.
Att det har fått styra då än att var etableringen ska ske någonstans.
Jag fattar och nu kommer vi nästan direkt in på hela etableringens resan, men vi pausar den lite, vi kommer tillbaka till den.
Vi får börja lite med vem du är.
Vi kanske ska bara så att folk får en känsla för, inte bara hur etablera här aktivitet och sig under sina 20 år, utan vem är Sara först kanske?
Sara utbildar sjuksköterska och styrer till barnmorska, aldrig jobbat som det dock.
Sjuksköterska jobbar jag som något år bara.
Därför att tillsammans med Eva startar Mattias och jag aktivitus.
Det blir mer och mer att göra, då fick man någonstans beslut över vad man vill fokusera på.
Vi kan också säga att Mattias är din man och ni grunder bolaget ihop.
2004 var detta.
Mattias är utbildad idrottsfriskerhårspedagog.
Vi kommer själva från en elitaktiv mantomarkbakgrund.
Vi drog själva ner till Tyskland och gjorde fysiologiska tester och fick hjälp att styra våran träning med hjälp av den datan de fick fram.
Vi tyckte att det var en tilltalande modell som inte fanns i Sverige.
I Sverige på den tiden kunde man göra fysiologiska tester av väldigt hög kvalitet, men det brukade se ut som att man fick ett dokument i handen med en massa data och så fick man gå hem och göra vad man ville med det.
Inte egentligen hjälpa att tolka den och använda den smart.
På den vägen har jag alltid varit extremt träningsintresserad.
Testat mycket idrotter, tävlat många idrotter och nerdat in mig.
Och kommer nog alltid att vara extremt träningsintresserad.
Är det det som är den roligaste kunden, det är när det kommer en träningsnerd som man får peta på procentdetaljerna?
Eller är det roligare att jobba med de här stora helheterna från början?
Ja, det beror lite på vad du frågar.
För att på Aktivitets har vi såklart jättemånga träningsnerdar som jobbar här och som älskar att arbeta med sitt intresse.
Och för min egen del så har det väl under årens lopp förändrats fokus.
Om jag då var den här nörden från början som var väldigt intresserad av datan och siffrorna så har det ju gått över till ett intresse i nuläget av bolagsbyggandet mer och kanske också mer kring, eller mer intresse kring folkhälsan och jobba med att förändra och jobba med ett företag.
Men är detta ditt första riktiga jobb?
Du sa att det hade varit ett år som sjuksköterska.
Har du jobbat ordentligt innan eller kom du bara in i arbetslivet, gjorde lite småjobb och sen var det egenföretagande från start?
Ja faktiskt, min pappa var egenföretagande så det kändes naturligt för jag har alltid haft extra kräkt på småjobb under uppväxten.
Efter att det är ett sjuksköterska, är det parallellt egentligen med det, så startade vi och aktivit oss och ja, när vi var lite aktiva mat-
och markcyklister så drev vi väl det som ett företag.
Vi var inte de bästa cyklisterna men vi var nog, skulle jag vilja hävda, de bästa på att skaffa oss sponsorer.
Det blir ett sätt att driva företag, man ska sälja in sig själv och man ska också vårda den relationen med sin sponsor.
Det var faktiskt några år där vi kunde försörja oss på cyklingen.
Som sagt utan att vi hade några SM-guld att skryta med men vi var duktiga på att ge någonting tillbaka.
Det var väl en typ av företagande och det mynnade ut i aktivitet kan man säga.
Fattar, det kan man ju för övrigt ge som en pointer till många människor som sysslar med träning och som gör det på hela tiden.
För jag gissar, vi får ju extremt mycket ansökningar om människor som vill bli sponsrade.
Och jag gissar att även Aktivitus får en del förfrågningar om kan ni hjälpa mig berätta gratis mot att jag lägger upp.
Men ofta är ju sådana ansökningar horribelt dåliga och ofta väldigt generiska.
Det finns ingenstans var de ska ge tillbaka eller var de ska, utan det är bara en sådan här, hej jag har såhär många följare, jag satsar hårt, ge mig någonting gratis.
Det kanske inte riktigt är det man vill se.
Exakt så, och det där är faktiskt ett ämne som jag tycker är superspännande, som jag gärna hade föreläst om, alltså om det är så på en idrottsförening eller för renskilda individer som har ett fokus långt fram högt upp.
Det finns så mycket att göra där och som sagt, det här företaget tittar ju inte förstånd på den här prestationen, utan de tittar ju på vem är du, vilket värde kan du skapa för bolaget, vad kan du ge mig för mervärden till medarbetarna som jobbar där, det finns så mycket kreativt man kan göra där.
Så tänk till där skulle jag säga.
När ni drar iväg i ansökan, det behövs inte så mycket ibland, något litet kul bara.
Framförallt kanske en förståelse för att det behöver vara en win-win åt båda håll och inte bara vävarenhet.
Kan du ta oss med på själva uppstartsåret när ni satte igång detta?
Hur gick själva uppstarten till?
Hur fick ni in första kunden?
Hur började det?
Nu är det tjugo år sedan men...
Det blev en väldigt mjuk övergång då, eftersom vi kom från den lite aktiva karriären.
Och den var väl inte aktivt avslutad när vi startade Aktivitus.
Vi startade först en enskild firma för att kunna ta in sponsorpengar den vägen.
Sen hittade vi på varumärket och Aktivitus.
Vi hade, jag kan faktiskt nämna, vi hade en sponsor i Stockholm Nordnet, där de var väldigt duktiga på att guida oss och coacha oss i vårt mottagande av sponsringen.
Där de frågade, vad kan ge oss tillbaka och vi vill ha det här?
Då hade vi som sagt, för att ni är i Tyskland, gjort konditionstester och tyckte att det fanns ett starkt syfte med att mäta för att sedan följa upp och därmed kunna påvisa någon typ av förändring då.
Så det gjorde vi faktiskt enklare konditionstester på deras personal i Stockholm.
Höll för någon föreläsning kring att komma igång och träna och vad vinsterna med att träna i kondition är.
Så började och sedan så tyckte vi också då att konditionstester borde vara mer lätt tillgängliga eftersom de ger så mycket.
Så då satte vi faktiskt upp testutrustning i vår lägenhet i Göteborg.
Och gjorde lite minitestklinik i ett av sovrummen där.
Hur mycket störde sig de som bodde under och över?
Nej det tror jag inte, det lät inte så mycket.
Det var bara en cykel till en början, inget löfande.
Så då vände vi oss primärt mot cyklister, som kom därifrån, hade vårt nätverk inom cykel.
Så en av Göteborgs största cykelklubbar, då Hisingen Cykelklubb, skickade ut ett erbjudande till.
Var på några nappade och kom hem till oss, då gjorde de här konditionstesterna.
Vi låg otroligt mycket tid på varje kund.
Då stod både Mattias och jag med på och gjorde testet, tog ett par timmar.
Sedan fick kunden gå hem och de fick komma tillbaka en eller två dagar senare och vi satt nere i soffan i säkert två, tre timmar och gick igenom den här träningsplaneringen.
Så det var extremt icke kostnadseffektivt.
Men vi gjorde någonting vi tyckte var roligt.
Vi kände att vi kunde göra skillnad.
Så för oss var det ju, ja, det var ett jättekul sätt att kunna leva och också kunna bestämma själv över sitt liv och sin inkomst.
Så ja, det var där det började.
Minns ni vad ni tog för en sån där test i början?
Kommer du ihåg vad det kostade?
Ja, men satt och letade efter det här med de faktiskt.
Jag har kvar några såna här bokningskalendrar från kanske 2010-2011.
Så det kostade en tredjedel av i tar idag.
Jag bara vet att när man går igenom såna här, jag jobbade ju som PT förut och fysisk coach innan detta och jag bara kommer ihåg när man började så här, först tog man ju ett par hundra lappar och sen skulle man gå upp till någon 500 och då började jag känna svettig när man pratade med kunden.
Man visste inte hur man skulle...
Ja exakt, exakt så.
Men det var ju väldigt bra skola.
Vi hade ju inte bråttom heller, vi behövde ju inte så mycket pengar för att gå runt om på våran litsatsning.
Men vi var ju väldigt nyhörda för vad kundarna efterfrågar och uppskattade.
Det var nog viktigt apropå det här med kundresan och hög kvalitet.
Du nämner Mattias här, din man och medgrundare.
Då har ni jobbat ihop i 20 år och innan det har ni kört mountainbike ihop.
Ganska sammansvetsat team då, får jag gissa.
Och eftersom ni både har fritidsintressen ihop och jobb ihop, det är ju lite speciellt.
Ja men det är speciellt, den frågan får vi ju ganska ofta.
Dessutom är vi ju här på era klinik nu och det är inte 1000 kvadrat, utan det är ju lite mer familjärt så ni springer väl på varandra ganska mycket under dagen.
Svaret på din fråga, vi vet ju inte så mycket annat för vi har alltid jobbat ihop.
Vi blev ju tillsammans när jag var 20, nu är jag ju 45.
Då drev vi ju som sagt ett företag ihop, i och med vår del som elitikariär, vi åkte iväg och tränade och tävlade tillsammans.
Så vi är sammansvetsade, det är klart att man kan bli jättetrötta på varandra, framförallt i vardagen.
När det gäller aktivitus och vårt sätt att arbeta ihop så har det ju fallit så väldigt naturligt.
Han sköter sitt och jag sköter mitt.
Det är sällan vi där, i den dialogen hamnar i konflikter eller att vi går på varandra.
Utan någon av oss brukar alltid sitta hemma och jobba, någon brukar vara på kliniken.
Så i den mån vi går på varandra så är det nog mer hemma faktiskt privat.
Så det funkar väldigt bra.
Det finns egentligen bara vid ett tillfälle under de här 20 åren som det blev ett problem och det var när det bara var vi två i början och vi hade så pass mycket att göra så att Mattias fick sitta och skriva ett träningsprogram på helgerna.
Kunderna hörde av sig och undrade vad var leveransen av mitt träningsprogram och han var så trött och sleten på att skriva de här programmen.
Och jag var ju den som hade kundkontakten och skulle se till att kunden blev nöjd, varför jag fick driva på honom att leverera det här programmet nu.
Och det blev ju också någonting som täder på vår privat relation.
Men det mynner också ut i att vi vågade göra vår första anställning då av en kollega som kunde avlasta.
Och det är ju ett jättestort och svårt beslut att göra det för man tycker ju själv att man gör allting bäst och vem ska vi våga släppa in i det här.
Men till slut så hade vi inget val.
Det var ju det bästa beslutet såklart.
Blir det ofta så att du och Mattias blir liksom teamet mot de andra eller är ni på varsin sida och tar teamet på varsin sida och så är de med och väljer vem som ska ha rätt när ni tar, brukar ni liksom hålla med varandra i de här stora besluten?
Ja, det gör vi.
Okej.
Och det är väl inget medvetet utan vi har väldigt, väldigt lika värderingar och ja, det är väldigt olika som personer men innerst inne så tycker vi väldigt, väldigt mycket samma.
Vilket tur.
Vem står för vilka egenskaper?
Jag är gasen och han är bromsen.
Så han kan också vara den kloka och förnuftiga.
Jag kör på, det kan bli fort och fel men jag gillar att saker och ting händer så det är en bra kombination.
Ja, ni har också fyra barn ihop.
Jag klagade lite här innan vi satt på podden att jag har två barn nu så jag är lite trött och som alla hör är lite förkyld att ha på podden.
Men du har fyra barn, eller ni har fyra barn och ni driver bolag ihop.
Jag har aldrig förstått folk som kan lösa den satsningen.
Jag tänker om en person jobbar väldigt mycket behöver den andra jobba lite mindre.
Jag är helt fascinerad av folk som löser den här kombinationen.
Kan du berätta lite grann om det där?
Ja, och det är egentligen samma sak där att vi vet ju inget annat.
Så det är klart att man kan jämföra med andra och tycka att...
Ni har ju haft en tid innan ni hade barn.
Ja, såklart.
För-
och vann-
och efter-barn.
Nej men, de har ju bara fått hänga med.
Och det är lättare sagt än gjort, därför att nu har vi en liten sladdis här som är två år och det är inte bara att släppa med honom, han är väldigt bångstyrig.
Men med de två första barnen så...
Alltså jag svarar ju i kundtelefoner med ett barn på axeln.
Därför att man hade inget val.
Och det funkade.
Och man sitter och jobbar när barnen sover eller man blev extremt effektiv med tiden när de började på förskolan och använde de timmarna smart.
Så...
Ja, men det har gått bra och nu är ett par av barnen så pass stora så att vi sitter ju såklart mycket vid middagsbordet och snackar företagande.
Den äldsta har börjat läsa i ekonomi nu och är väldigt inne på entreprenörskap.
Det är superkul att se att det är tänket och att målsättningen går i arv.
Det är riktigt roligt.
Sen har vi inte lyckats få idrottsintresset i arv, vilket grämer oss och frustrerar oss oerhört mycket, men jag tror ändå någonstans att när de är vuxna så kommer de ändå att bli aktivt tränande personer även om de nu under tårnåren då ska sätta sig på tvärande.
Ja, nu vill jag inte låta negativt, men är det så du upplever att människor gör att det är helt plötsligt när de blir vuxna och börjar att träna.
Nu är det äldste som är sjutta nu, han valde ändå själv att vilja springa ut i borsrar nu.
Utan det handlar mer om att de inte har velat gå och organisera träning i någon form.
Gjorde ni en liten high-five under bordet och när han sade det?
Absolut, ja.
Vi kan ju slåss om det hemma, min flickvän är ju lärare och tycker givetvis att utbildning är det viktigaste som finns i livet och att de ska studera under lång tid och det är det man ska göra.
Och jag är ju företagare och tycker att det viktigaste som finns är att man börjar jobba snabbt och man kommer ut och man gör sin egen grej.
Och det där är så spännande.
Ja, och det är små barn små bekymmer, säger man.
Men de två stora nu då, jag vet inte hur många timmar vi har lagt senaste tiden på att debattera och diskutera, Mattias och jag.
Vilken roll vill vi ha i vårt uppfostrande då?
Jag kommer själv från en uppväxt där det inte har satsat några krav på mina studier eller min prestation i skolan.
Vilket jag i nuläget tycker är bra, samtidigt som jag har gamla barnomsvänner som läkare och advokat.
Frågan jag ställer mig då, kopplat till det du säger, är de lyckligare människor för att de läste några år till och kanske tjänar lite mer.
Nej det tror jag inte.
För mig har det varit väldigt viktigt och jag uppskattar supermycket nu när jag är där, jag är med mitt eget bolag, att ha fått göra min egen grej.
Det är klart att det kanske inte passar alla, men jag stöttar ju dig Joel fullt ut i det du säger.
Jag ska ta över det hem och säga att det finns skräm på min sida.
Helt underbart.
Jag tycker att det är skitsvårt för att, det vet ju du också att det inte är skitroligt att driva företag alltid och det går ju åt helvete för de bästa, så det är vad det är.
Det hade det gjort för oss också att inte driva knäppa i huvudet och ändå enträga att välja att fortsätta.
Därför att det har ju inte varit det smartaste ekonomiska valet alla gånger såklart.
Nej, så är det.
Eller vad ska man säga, lyckliga val, i stunden är det ju tungt liksom.
Men nu pratar jag med dig för att ni faktiskt har lyckats driva upp ett bra företag.
Det finns ju 99 personer till jag hade kunnat prata med som inte har gjort det och som hade sagt att fan ni borde bara stanna åt skolan.
Men det är ju roligt, samtidigt.
I alla fall, vi ska inte fastna i barnuppfostran.
Kan du dela med dig lite om hur din arbetsdag ser ut idag?
Jag gissar att som du sa från början var du med mest fokus på kundkontakt och sånt där.
Men vad sysslar du med idag?
Ja, som vd på Aktivitet så har du övergripande ansvaret såklart.
Dels är det en fri roll, vilket passar mig superbra.
Jag har svårt att se att jag skulle gå tillbaka till jobb som sjuksköterska eller barnmorska med ett 7-5-jobb.
Utan jag älskar att gå upp morgonen och ta tag i det som jag känner är viktigt och det jag har glädje för just då.
Jag försöker alltid att börja arbetsdagen med ett träningspass.
Dels för att få det gjort.
Det är ju enklare att börja med att fokusera på det så det är klart sedan.
Men också för att jag känner att det får mig att förbättra stressstoligheten och öka prestationen.
Då kan det vara en löktur, gym eller tennis.
Sen som idag så upptäcker jag att det var någon problem med lönefilen.
Då får jag sätta mig och hantera det lite akut.
Det är klart att det är mycket problemlösning att driva företag.
Särskilt måndagar brukar det gå 2-3 timmar på måndag morgon.
Det är något problemlösning.
Sen så är det mycket möten så klart, olika typ.
Jag försöker vara tillgänglig på kliniken till mina kollegor, åtminstone två gånger i veckan.
Där jag bara finns där och lyssnar in och stöttar upp.
Den är superviktig för mig, också personligen därför att jag älskar att hänga med mina kollegor.
Många är mina nära vänner.
Så det ger mig super mycket energi.
Och ja, vad gör jag mer?
Det kan vara att jag dammsuger, om man säger att man behöver dammsuga så jag drar och köper kaffe om man behöver köpa kaffe.
Vad är det som ser till att allting flyter på?
Vilken roll av ditt nuvarande jobb är det?
Om du fick outsourca en del här som du verkligen inte tycker om, om finns det någon del som du fortfarande är såhär det här tycker jag verkligen inte är roligt, men du gör det för att du måste liksom ta i det.
Ja, jag har nog varit rätt duktig på faktiskt att det ligger där bort de uppgifterna som jag inte tycker är så roliga och som jag också såklart inte heller var eller är så bra på.
Så egentligen, nu läget inte faktiskt.
Det är superskönt.
Men om det är din roll, vad är Mattias roll nu?
Mattias jobbar väl mer och mer åt marknadshållet.
Han träffar fortfarande kunder och gör tester, en till två dagar i veckan.
Sen så, mer och mer med att sköta webbsida, sociala medier, nyhetsbrev.
Får vi ut det i världen.
Ni har haft bolaget i 20 år.
Hur gör man för att inte stagnera eller att liksom fastna i gamla rutiner?
Utan hur gör ni för att hitta nya områden?
Här ska vi fokusera, här ska vi utveckla detta, här ska vi ta tillvara på den här tekniken, de här produkterna.
Hur gör man för att inte bara långsamt, långsamt själv dö?
Om jag ska låta läsa.
Det är ju en bra fråga och det pratar vi om ibland.
För oss är det väldigt viktigt att fortsätta utveckla sig hela tiden.
Om det är så i ökad omsättning, vilket är en del av det, att öppna en ny testklinik, att man känner att någonting händer hela tiden, att man utvecklas och går framåt.
Det är helt avgörande för vår motivation.
Hur gör vi då det?
Det är att lyssna in, vad är det kunderna efterfrågar?
Vad är det vi saknar idag?
Det är också så vi har vuxit och byggt vårt bolag organiskt att vi har gått dit efterfrågan finns.
Det är väldigt motiverande att se att om ett nytt affärsområde, genom att lägga lite krut där eller skruva lite på den tjänsten, så kan det leda nån vart.
Bara tro på att det finns en utvecklingsmöjlighet någonstans, det är ju väldigt motiverande.
Sen gäller det att hålla sig uppdaterad.
Vad är det som händer och sker i branschen?
Vad är på gång, alltid från tekniska hjälpmedel till AI, till vad konkurrenterna gör, men framförallt vad kunderna efterfrågar?
Ni verkar, och du får ju rätta med om jag är fel här, men det verkar som att den stora businessen är att göra de här olika testerna och sen jobba med träning och coaching utifrån det.
Ni har inte börjat fundera på att lägga till olika affärsben, som att ni säljer produkter kopplade till detta, eller ni säljer väl lite små produkter, men du vet att det verkligen blir en business, det är inget sånt.
Det är ju en annan affärsområde såklart.
Absolut, det här med vår försäljning och hårdvara, det var ju under ett par års tid så var det liksom vårt starkaste ben och då är det som höll upp vår verksamhet faktiskt.
Sen dalade den försäljningen ut, eftersom det fanns nya produkter och nya konkurrenter.
Så att idag så är den väldigt, väldigt liten.
Vi funderar väl mer och mer på det här som du säger om ett helhetskoncept, att kunderna kommer till oss därför att de vill ha hjälp att utvecklas i sin kondition, men vad är det som hindrar dem utöver, vad är det mer vi kan hjälpa till, men det är klart att de råkar ut från sjukdom eller någon skada, om de kanske vill att de ska träffa en apropat, eller en fysioterapeut, eller en läkare.
Då behöver vi ha det tillgängligt eller i nätverket.
Så absolut, vilket vi också är inne på att se till helheten ännu mer.
Jag tänker, det finns två olika sider där.
Antingen kan man bli hardcore-fokuserad.
Jag tänker att ni hade kunnat jobba bara med tester och göra det väldigt standardiserat.
Bara pumpa ut tester med någon sorts efterföljande analys, eller att man går och jobbar mot ett helhetsgrepp, mycket mer så som du beskriver.
Vilken av dem triggade dig mest?
Och vad tror du att ni kommer röra er de närmsta åren?
Ja att bara stå och pumpa tester, det var väl, det är så många upplever oss, att vi som konditionsfabriken, där man kommer och gör ett laktatester, så går man hem.
Men jag tycker eller tror nog ändå att det finns någon typ av begränsning där, åtminstone i Sverige, hur många är intresserade av den tjänsten.
Så det är väl också där vi har blivit bättre på att coacha våra kunder som kommer också, att inte bara förse dem med testdata, utan också löpande, bidåhålla dem i systemet och hjälpa dem.
Om man ser till skalbarhet så är det ju våra företagstjänst där det verkligen finns stor potential.
Nu upplever jag inte riktigt att marknaden är mogen för att lämna det här.
Det är det reaktiva sättet att jobba med hälsa.
Vi är extremt proaktivt och drivna och pratar väldigt varmt om det sättet att arbeta såklart.
De flesta av våra företagskunder är ju it-konsultbolag och det är ju inte någon slump att där är man lite mer på tårna och man behöver vara det kanske för att vara en attraktiv arbetsgivare.
Där har det passat våra tjänster väldigt väl in.
Är det samma personalgrupp hos dig som sköter testområdet som företagskunder?
Bra fråga, nej det är det ju inte.
De flesta av våra kollegor är ju de här tränningsnördarna som själva kommer från kanske en elitaktiv löparbakgrund eller cykelbakgrund.
Som kan gå igång på att förstå ett lagtal av test och tycka att det är kul.
Ja, och som verkligen brinner för att få göra det här på sitt arbete och också förmedla den kunskapen till kunderna.
De som jobbar som hälsocoacher på företag har faktiskt nästan alltid en annan personlighet och andra intressen helt enkelt.
Så det är oftast inte samma personer.
Vilka passar du mest med?
Kan du prata med alla?
Ibland har man kollegor som är så här, ja fan du är så insnöjd på detta så jag förstår inte vad jag ska prata om.
Och ibland är folk så här, nästan för sociala.
Nu är jag social när vi sitter här men jag gillar det när man sammanfattar och går vidare.
Men många av mina kollegor är ju väldigt sociala och trevliga för de pratar ju med kunder hela tiden.
Och jag kan ju bara bli knäpp på att de inte bara kan bara ge mig sammanfattningen så vi klarar sig.
För några år sedan skulle jag såla mig till tränningsnördfacket, men faktiskt inte idag, utan nu ska jag nog säga att jag brinner verkligen för att ordna friskvårdstjänst och att få barnen och människor att må bättre.
Och har väl mer gemensamt med det gänget.
Men jag hoppas och tror att mina kollegor, även inom tränningsnörderiet, har förtroende.
Även om jag inte går in i en diskussion med faxnacket.
Det är Mattias mycket bättre på.
Ja, jag förstår.
Man vet vart man stoppar upp för att bibehålla kompetensen.
Ja, och det känner jag också trygg med.
Som jag har så duktiga kollegor som är så kompetenta inom tränningsfysiologi, så känner jag inte heller att jag behöver inte vara bäst där.
Jag kan vara trygg i att andra kan ta det snacket mycket bättre.
Kan vi inte fastna lite i hur du ser på din ledarroll, speciellt ni har ju flera anläggningar.
Någonstans blir det ju att sätta ett varumärke, hur ni jobbar, hur er approach ska vara mot kund.
Du nämnde förut svårigheten att ta in den första kollegen, för då vill man ju styra allting och sånt där.
Hur säger du att du skulle ha utvecklats här under de här 20 åren som ledare eller chef?
Är det någonting du tänker aktivt på eller?
Nu blir det jättemånga frågor, men jag vill bara ha en generell syn på.
Nej men det är ju någonting som har vuxit fram såklart.
Du är ju ingen natural born leader, eller vad du är från början.
Nej det skulle jag inte säga.
Jag vet inte om jag är den bästa ledaren nu heller.
Jag känner, så länge jag känner att jag har glör och passion för det jag gör, så tror jag att jag kan antaceras med mina kolleger, att det dels trivas men också att prestera.
Sen jag är ju som sagt, inte skolad företagare verkan inom ekonomi eller att leda.
Jag har väl gjort en del rätt ändå eftersom jag har så, återigen, grymt duktiga kollegor och de har ju inte varit här om vi misskötte våra ledarpositioner.
Vilket jag är jätteglad över och superstolt för också såklart.
Vi gör såhär då, vad är du bäst på som ledare och vad är du sämst på?
Jag är nog bäst på att se och bekräfta mina kollegor.
Få dem att känna sig viktiga och trivas.
Jag är sämst på att sitta lugnt i båten och kanske invänta rätt tillfälle.
Det kan bli lite för ofta, lite fort och fel.
Vilket kan drabba en kollega då, vilket är jättetragiskt.
Därför att det är aldrig mitt syfte.
Men så har det blivit några gånger, då är det bara att be med ursäkt och bromsa in och försöka hitta rätt spår igen.
De här olika anläggningarna som ni har, för nu är ni sex anläggningar, stämmer det?
Ja, med Åreo.
Är det bara denna som fulläggs av er?
Hur funkar konceptet?
Ni har lite olika bolag och det finns ett huvudbolag.
Bolagsstrukturen ser ut som så att vi har vårt mordobolag, det är Aktivytens AB.
Det är också det vi startade först.
Där Mattias och jag är majoritetsägare, sen har vi några minoritetsägare i mordobolaget.
Sen har alla andra bolag, är ju dotterbolag till Aktivytens AB.
Då heter de Kondition Stockholm AB, Kondition Malmö AB och så vidare.
Och då brukar det se ut så att platschefen i ett dotterbolag är minoritetsägare.
Och det tycker vi har varit en bra modell, därför att då skapar man incitament att vara med och bidra om man känner en annan delaktighet.
Har det varit samma, de som är platschefer på de ställena, är det också de som är delägare i mordobolaget?
Nej, det är externa och det är också de som sitter i styrelsen.
Okej, då fattar jag.
Någon person kommer till er oftast och vill starta upp någonting liknande, och då startar ni tillsammans ett bolag i en annan stad.
Har ni då ett färdigt koncept som ni rullar ut, eller har man en diskussion om hur det ska funka beroende på den?
Nu är det mer eller mindre ett färdigt koncept.
Avtalen ser ut på samma sätt och vi har ju en vi vet ju vad det är som krävs, vilken utrustning vi behöver köpa in, vilken typ av lokal vi behöver, vilken omsättning vi behöver komma uppe ganska snabbt, vilken typ av medarbetare vi behöver på plats.
Så att det går snabbare och snabbare att få igång en ny enhet eftersom vi har våra centrala funktioner på plats.
Och hur delaktiga är ni i, hur ofta är du på en sån här annan anläggning och slår en kik och sådär, eller lämnas det över till den som är på plats?
Det kan vara lite olika, det finns ju ingen struktur i det, utan det är lite mer ad hoc att man gör ett besök i samband med någonting.
Det är klart att i Malmö och Stockholm är jag ju oftare.
Men det är också en modell som har satt sig allt eftersom det här är hur vi ska jobba mot platscheferna.
För det är ju klart att det är superviktigt för oss att bibehålla kvaliteten åt leveransen till kund, så likadant utoavsett vilken klinik de väljer att besöka.
Så det så följer vi ju våra kunderutvärderingar, inte slaviskt men regelbundet.
Och där vi också börjat följa MPS score.
Den feedbacken vi får tillbaka har vi nu också resurser att ta hand om.
För några år sedan så var vi kanske inte så intresserade av att ta emot utvärderingen därför att vi exakt vi visste inte vad vi skulle göra med det och det ser ju ännu sämre ut om man inte kan ge återkoppling.
Så vi har väl alltid varit av den åsikten att om vi har en missnöjd kund så gäller det att kompensera och gärna överkompensera.
Så kanske vi kan få en ambassadör istället.
Men åter till hur vi kan kvalitetssäkra.
Då har vi ju, vi samlar alla platscheferna regelbundet i interna möten där vi går igenom olika saker och vi arbetar regelbundet med att ta fram kvalitetssäkringsmodeller och dokument som vi försöker efterleva.
Ja, den är superviktig men svår såklart.
Ja, jag har väldigt knepigt.
Hur är det att ta in en ny person i sitt bolag om ni har både delägare i moderbolaget och som de här dotterbolagen?
Hur gör ni när ni hittar de här personerna?
Hur känner ni av att det är rätt person?
Det här vill jag jobba med de nästa 45 åren.
Hur gör man liksom den kevin?
Fram tills för ganska kort tid sedan så har vi gått på magkänsla.
Det är oftast blivit bra rätt.
Någon gång har det blivit fel.
Då har vi fått se till att avsluta.
Vilket har varit oerhört svårt och jobbigt såklart.
Därför blir det väldigt personligt.
När det gäller styrelsen för moderbolaget och för hela aktivet så är vi väl egentligen just nu i ett skede där vi känner att vi behöver och vill utveckla styrelsearbetet.
Därför att det har varit lite grann av ett forum där jag har rapporterat till styrelsen och så nickar de och tycker att man var bra och fortsätter på inslagen väg.
Men för att utvecklas och ta nästa steg så vill vi mer ha det som ett beslutande organ eller mer frågasättande.
Och då behöver vi förändra någonting där för att de har hängt med väldigt länge och kom väl in lite grann som kompisar till oss.
De var närmaste i nätverket kan man säga.
Så att, ja, där ser jag nog att att vi har tagit in en extern person som inte delar och det har gett jättemycket.
Det inspirerar ju att ta det vidare.
Vad är det ni behöver pushas in om och vad är det...
Här känner du att det här behöver utmanas lite grann.
Ja men det är väl att...
Kanske våga göra saker utanför annorlunda och framför allt om man ska byta spår, att man får in kompetens.
Kanske finns det en eller två personer som har gjort liknande resa kanske på en högre nå, förhoppningsvis då.
Som kan bidra med lite nytt för att det är klart efter 20 år, vi blir ju extremt hemma blinda och många i styrelsen har suttit med många många år också.
Vi behöver ha in lite nytt tänk.
Och bli lite provocerade.
Jag har ju några, eller mina kollegor är ganska outspoken, så när jag gör fel så får jag höra det liksom.
Och jag kan alltid bli lika irriterad när jag får de här sms-en eller samtalen att fan Joel, du fuckar upp här liksom, löst detta.
Och då, det är ju bra, man behöver ju bli provocerad och utmanad, men det är ju alltid fruktansvärt irriterande.
Första reaktionen är ju alltid, va, på tyst nu.
För jag hade en tanke och sen får man efter fem minuter inse att, ja men det var inte rätt tanke.
Just det.
Det du säger är att du först blir irriterad på de som hör av sig och gnäller, fast det mynnar ut är att du blir irriterad på dig själv.
För det var du som gjorde felet, ja jag känner igen det där 100 procent.
Så jag gillar att få kritiken på sms så jag får lugna mig i fem minuter först.
Så jag kan bemöta det på ett bra sätt.
Det är bra, har du sagt det till om att det är svårt att vilja ha?
Nej men det är ganska inne.
Man lärt sig.
Ja jag tror det.
Jag är inte så rolig att prata med i telefon faktiskt.
Nu låter jag som en hemsk människa, det är jag inte, men jag är inte så bra att få ta kritik i första läget.
Det är bra, då är det inget problem så länge du känner till din svaga sida och kan hantera det.
Det var bra tips.
Man säger alltid att man inte ska ge kritik i skriven form, utan bara face to face.
Jag gillar att få det först så att jag kan bara komma in i att just det detta är mitt fel, nu kan vi ta diskussionen.
Det där är också något vi har diskuterat mycket internt det sista året, hur ger vi varandra kritik?
Vissa är bra på att ge och ta, andra är sämre på att ge och ta.
Där har vi kommit fram till gemensamt att om man ska ge kritik, om det är svårvajskriftligt eller muntligt, börja med någonting positivt.
Sen var snygg den där tavlan blev.
Den skulle jag vilja ha på min väg, jag hade nog tagit lite med ljusblått istället.
Det funkar.
Man kan göra det i en sandwich, man ska säga, bra dåligt bra.
Vi kör bara dåligt direkt.
Det blir för jobbigt.
Ibland kan det bli lite kryssat.
Fan vad trevlig du är som person.
Det här gjorde du skitfel på, du får lösa detta.
Men kul att träffa din flickvän för en vecka, hon var härlig.
Det är en process att få det att låta naturligt.
Vi är jättedelika, visst är jag superduktiga på det.
Man gillar dem redan när de säger något dåligt.
Jag hade en gammal kollega där jag jobbade, jag var inhyrt som vd under en period.
Hon sa alltid att din bästa förmåga är att få negativa besked att låta positiva.
Medan jag kan inte ens få positiva besked att låta positiva, utan de låter också negativa.
Jag tyckte det var så jävla roligt sagt.
Jag kommer dit med någonting jag tänker är en grym nyhet och alla bara blir ledsna typ.
Det var ganska roligt sagt.
Ni har ju ganska mycket tjänster i det här bolaget.
Ni har både coaching, ni har testerna, ni har olika resor som jag förstår det, ni har företagsdelen, privata delen.
Kan det inte bli lite rörigt för kund när man kommer, man kanske har blivit rekommenderad er ett namn och så går man in på hemsidan så blir man lite så här, vad är det egentligen jag hamnar någonstans?
Ja, ja 100% ja på din fråga.
Och det är faktiskt precis där vi står just nu, att vi har börjat titta på vilka av våra affärsområden är lönsamma, vilka är det inte.
Och de som inte är lönsamma, de kommer vi att skala bort innan året till slut, skulle jag vilja hävda, därför att det tar ju tid och energi.
Nu finns de där av en anledning, därför att vi är luststyda inom aktivitet, vi gillar att dra igång saker och testa nya projekt.
Och ibland hänger de kvar utan att det är ett aktivt beslut, och kostar pengar egentligen.
Och där behöver vi ju, dels för den egen skull, för det är en viktig målsättning att förbättra vår lönsamhet.
Vi behöver ta tag i det och rensa upp, men också för kundernas skull.
Det är klart att vi upplevs som, det kan vara jätterörigt när man kommer in på vår webbsida första gången och vill boka ett lactatest, fastnar i en massa annat och aldrig kommer till bokningen.
Och framförallt om vi nu lyfter vår friskvårdstjänst, om en HR-chef kommer in på vår webbsida och ser att vi har triat någon resor och vi säljer monarchscyklar och vi gör olika typer av avancerade fysiologiska tester, då blir de bort trollare där innan de ens har kommit till vad är det vi bjuder företag.
Så den är superviktig.
Där ligger också såklart, vi kommer att snickra om våra webbsida så att det blir ett tydligare koncept då mot privatpersoner och företag.
Har ni haft någon sån där satsning genom åren som ni verkligen har brunnit för men som aldrig gick, som ni fick lägga ner, för att det flög liksom inte?
Ja, men flera stycken skulle jag vilja säga.
Jag trodde du satsade inte på en men nej det var många av er.
Det är flera stycken och där måste man våga bryta.
Där vi också har kill your darlings, att man vågar ta bort någonting som också funkar för att man tror att det kan funka ännu bättre om man skruvar lite grann.
Men våra resor till exempel, de är ju inte lönsamma.
Man har en kollega som brinner oerhört mycket för att köra dem.
Det handlar ju om att motivera den kollegen kanske åt något annat håll och hitta andra saker.
För det är väldigt viktigt för oss att få jobba med det vi tycker är kul.
Det är ett av huvudsyftena med att driva bolag såklart, men det får inte vara till vilket pris som helst.
Man vill ju testa om man får ge det lite tid, men går det inte så går det inte.
Ja.
Det är så det funkar.
Finns det någon period av företagsbyggandet här som verkligen har varit tuff när det var nära att det kommer inte funka?
Ja, senaste åren under pandemin och krig och ekonomiska svårigheter till höger och vänster så har vi faktiskt suttit ganska tryggt.
Vi har byggt upp en tillräckligt stabil plattform och våra kunder är väl kanske...
Våra kunder är höginkomstdagar och kanske inte har varit drabbade på samma sätt.
Vi har ju ändå haft tillräckligt stort slöde även om vi behövt vara smarta och skruva lite grann i utgifter och vad vi erbjuder.
Men det var ju några år för tolv, tretton år sen när det var tuffa tider och där ekonomin inte gick ihop sig och då fick vi gå in och strypa Mattias och min lön.
Det har vi gjort under flera perioder under de här 20 åren.
Det har funkat för stunden och vi har lyckats hämta hem och anpassa vårt privatliv efter det.
Nu omsätter vi så pass mycket att det skulle nästan inte räcka.
Vilket vore bra och dåligt.
Får man säga att alla har strypat, det är svårt.
Ja, det är klart att det är lite skrämmande och lite läskigt och det innebär att vi måste ha ännu bättre koll på siffrorna för att inte hamna där.
Samtidigt är det ganska skönt.
Det behöver inte vi oroas för att vi inte kan plocka ut någon lön.
Det har varit tufft många gånger och jag tror väl att det är väl det som många ger upp, men där vi ändå har trott på det vi gör och inte velat släppa det.
Vilket vi är glada för idag såklart.
Jag förstår.
Å andra sidan, någon annan sida om inte där.
Här kände ni att ni verkligen tog nästa steg.
Här gick ni från att vara, ska man säga, ett hobbyprojekt med en liten start-up.
Eller det var någonting som ni gjorde som en liten till att bli ett riktigt företag, quotation marks.
Såklart när vi flyttar från lägenheten in i en riktig lokal, då känner man det.
När vi tog in första medarbetaren, det är väl två stora milstolpar.
Sen så är det smågrejer när vi köper ett löpband och erbjuder löptester och inte bara cykeltester.
När vi öppnade Testkliniket i Stockholm, det är såklart en milstolpe.
När vi paketerade och började sälja våra friskvårdstjänster i företag och också Storby.
Det har varit många sådana milstolpar.
Vilken var mest, vilken fick dig att känna den där känslan och att det här var lite coolt.
Vilken var liksom goast.
Det behöver inte vara den största utan det kan ju bara vara en sån här.
Det här är rätt häftigt.
Ja, det var nog något som var riktigt häftigt.
Då hade vi en privat kund här på Kliniken i Göteborg som var vd för ett ganska stort bolag.
Då var det faktiskt han som också hjälpte oss att paketera våra friskvårdstjänster.
Han hade en tro på att konditionen bidrog till vilken mån hans medarbetare kunde producera på arbetstid eller inte.
Så då satte vi ihop den här friskvårdstjänsten.
Vi skulle ut och köra några bolag med 500 anställda och jag skulle vara med på en kickoff där och presentera det i upplägget.
Då omsatte inte vi mer än 3-4 miljoner på aktivitets.
Men det var en jättestor grej att han trodde på oss och att vi fick det förtroendet.
Prata infall de här människorna som lyssnade på det jag hade att säga och som faktiskt också skulle vara med och ta del av den tjänsten som vi skulle leverera.
Det var ett häftigt minne.
Jag förstår.
Vad roligt.
Det är kul de här.
Det är ju någonstans de som får en att kära på.
Man tänker att, jag tror att många felaktigt har en bild av att man tänker att företagsbyggande handlar väldigt mycket om att bygga en ekonomisk plattform och även om bolaget blir stort så finns det ju ofta ganska lite pengar rent privat i bolaget utan det är mer bolaget som har pengar och sånt.
Däremot så får man ju den här friheten, du pratade förut om att man kanske inte vill jobba 9-5 eller sånt där, utan man får jobba lite när man vill, man kan välja lite sina uppgifter och så får man de här ögonblicken som är såhär, fan det här är rätt coolt, det här är ett ball, jag kan påverka människor på det här sättet.
Det är ganska häftigt.
Ja men det är värt så mycket.
Kan du beskriva lite framtiden?
Det är såklart svårt, vi kommer från otaliga black swans här med pandemi och lågkonjunktur och räntechockar och nu är det krig här och där och allt sånt där.
Men om du någonstans skulle spå de närmaste åren, hur tänker du kring utvecklingen förutom att göra hemsidan lite mer tydlig?
Ja det är väl en bra början.
Nej men fortsatt utveckling med ökad omsättning.
Vi har ju våra mål där såklart.
Sen handlar det om att bryta ner de här sifformålen i någon typ av tydligare actions.
Framtids, bara för något år sen så har vi satt drömmålar om vi ska omsätta SI och så, men egentligen inte kopplat till något mer än en dröm man har.
När man lär sig att förstå den kopplingen för att det ska finnas någon realitet i siffrorna så måste det också finnas någon tydlig handlingsplan eller någon utstakad väg att gå.
Men sedan de närmsta fem åren så ser vi en expansion internationellt.
Det är klart att man först kan titta på Finland, Norge, Danmark, men det skulle likväl kunna bli Tyskland, England eller Holland.
Det har återigen att göra väldigt mycket med att vi hittar rätt person med rätt driv och nätverk som kan hjälpa oss med det.
Vad är det som lockar med internationella och vad är svårigheterna med det?
Det som lockar är ju återigen det här med att man söker någon utveckling hela tiden, att om vi nu finns i sex städer i Sverige så blir det ganska naturligt att kanske söka sig vidare.
Och en utmaning är väl att vi, man vet helt enkelt inte vad som väntar och hur det ska ta sig emot.
Det är klart man kan göra sin research och se om det finns någon liknande tjänst etablerad, gör det inte det.
Då får man börja litegrann från noll, precis som vi har gjort i Sverige.
Här har vi någonstans skapat vår egen efterfrågan efter det vi gör eftersom vi inte har direkt konkurrens eller vi har ju varit marknadsledande ganska länge.
Och det finns för-
och nackdelar med det såklart.
Och sen när det gäller friskvården, den traditionella företagshälsovården inom Sverige, det är ju ganska unikt.
Det har man ju inte i alla länder, där man ser annorlunda på arbetsgivare och arbetstagare.
Så det finns ju både möjligheter.
Finns det en legal problematik kring att gå utanlands?
För här, klart ni måste fördela jättetajta GDPR-regler och sånt där när man gör sådana här grejer, men räknas sånt här som sjukvård utanlands?
Alltså jag vet inte, eller är det på samma sätt att man kan såhär, nej, kom hit och så gör vi lite tester på dig, och så är det fine liksom.
Ja, nej men det är ju en bra fråga, det är sant man får ta reda på det under resans gång.
Utan det får man ju, det gör man bara, det får man lösa.
Ibland är det ju lite sådär, halvflumigt, såhär, det här får man inte ha utanlands, det här får man ha, okej.
Nej men vi är väldigt lösningsorienterade, vi tar reda på det vi behöver ta reda på, så hanterar vi det bara.
Det finns alltid lösningar.
Det finns alltid den här känslan av att vi vill ändå hitta på detta.
Jag tycker det är fascinerande, det är ändå 20 år som han har gjort det.
Det är någonstans min madröm när man vaknar upp en morgon och bara känner att jag inte är så sugen längre.
Nej, men så har det ju samtidigt varit som tur är i kortare perioder och kanske inte så ofta, att man känner att fan vad trött jag är på det här nu, nu vill jag verkligen göra någonting annat.
Och så kanske man någonstans faktiskt har tagit tag i att göra någonting annat och börja undersöka möjligheten om det är så, att hoppa på någon utbildning eller vad man skulle göra där.
Men det minnar ju alltid ut i att man ändå någonstans till slut gör ett aktivt val, att nej, jag vill jobba med ett aktivt, jag är inte färdig, jag vill tillbaka.
Och så har man fokus där igen och på ett sätt tror jag det kan vara ganska nyttigt att bryta sig loss mentalt under en period, bara för att sedan aktivt välja att det är det jag vill vara.
Så att man inte går omkring och känner sig missnöjd och fastlåst.
För du har ju alltid val.
Det är ingen av er som har pausat i någon omgång från bolaget.
Nej.
Bara kortare tid mentalt.
Ja exakt, det får man faktiskt göra.
Jag gissar att ni har några semesterdagar att klocka in så då kanske man får checka ut ibland lite längre.
Man har det inne stående så att säga.
Ja precis.
Har du några avslutande tips för om man ska in i träningsvärlden och hälsovärlden den är ofta ganska passionsdriven, det är ofta ganska låg lönsamhet, det är ofta folk går in där några år som unga och sen hoppar de ut igen och man har mycket storslagna planer med det skit i sig och sånt där.
Har du några tips om man vill in i den här världen och vad man ska tänka på som man kanske inte tänker på när man är färsk?
Nej men såklart uthållighet, för det har varit nyckeln för oss.
Det tog jättemånga år innan vi hade någon lönsamhet.
Det var ju dopade siffror till en början eftersom vi som sagt ofta inte tog någon lön.
Så uthållighet om du verkligen tror på det du gör.
Det är väl super att söka bekräftelse någonstans förutom att hos sig själv då att det ändå är en bra affärsidé.
Men att våga skruva i affärsidéen och verkligen lyssna in kunderna.
Att det finns någon sorts stans där.
Ni gick några år där utan att plocka ut lön utan bara för att hålla bolaget flytande.
Vad var det som gjorde att ni sedan blev ett mer professionellt bolag och faktiskt kunde börja plocka ut lön?
Vad var liksom de första stegen där?
Det är ju en skola att driva företag, att starta ett företag.
Du lärde ju varje dag eller vecka, varje månad, du lärde någonting nytt.
Om man då inte är helt knäpp i huvudet så tar man ju förhoppningsvis med sig det då och använder det till sin fördel framåt när man hamnar i en liknande situation.
Vi har helt enkelt blivit skickligare på att hitta den här balansen mellan intäkter och utgifter.
Kanske bygga korrekta koncept som folk vill betala för på ett annat sätt.
Ja, precis.
Att också smarta är marknadsföring, inte lägga så mycket pengar där för att det är klart att om vi jämför vår verksamhet med en fysioterapiklinik som får alla sina patienter eller kunder från sjukvården utan att behöva lägga en enda krona på sälj är marknadsföring.
Sikt vad sjuk man är på dagens.
Många gånger har man tyckt att det är fel grej vi höll på med för att vi måste jaga varje enskild kund dagligen.
Att bli lite smartare där, jobba lite mer effektivt, det är också något man blir skickligare med åren.
Så att det är väldigt mycket sammantagat.
Få in rätt kolleger som hjälper till och driver upp och driver fram, som får kunderna att vilja komma tillbaka.
Skruva lite grann i tjänsterna, hur de ser ut, hitta rätt pris.
Det är så många bitar som måste falla på plats, men att hela tiden man har lyhört och inte ge sig där.
Pusha på några år och ständigt utvecklas.
Fan det är ett skittråkigt råd men det låter rätt.
Du har ingen snabb skickfix som gjorde att man var okej.
Jag älskar att leva det här fria livet, trots riskerna såklart och baksidorna med sena kvällar.
Du säljer in det stenhårt här i slutet.
Jag fattar, jag fattar precis.
Vi har aldrig ångrat oss en sekund nu då, när vi verkligen kan.
Nu älskar vi vårt jobb och våra kollegor.
Och den stoltheten att man har så duktiga kollegor som kommer till sitt jobb och trivs.
De har ett riktigt jobb tack vare oss.
Det är ju en super, det är stort.
Kan du fortfarande känna den här känslan av att du driver ju ett, för jag kan uppleva den känslan att mitt jobb är inte ett riktigt jobb.
Alltså att mina kollegor jobbar hos mig fast då har de liksom inte ett riktigt jobb, utan de hade kunnat gå till ett riktigt företag istället, men de väljer att jobba här hos.
Ja, exakt så känns det.
Undrar hur länge man känner så.
Jag tror aldrig att det skulle sluta.
Ja, exakt så.
Ja, Sara, tack för en fantastisk intervju och hoppas folk får med sig mycket glädje och lärdomar från denna.
Tack så mycket.
Ja, tack, kul att vara med.
Nu är jag social när vi sitter här men jag gillar när man sammanfattar och går vidare.